I put this clip out talking about a
morning routine pretty basic but it went
get into Stella the most common comment
was something along the lines of tell me
you don't have kids without telling me
that you don't have kids must be easy
for you to say I have a daughter to get
up in the morning tell me what that
mindset gets you it says I'm in a
situation which I cannot get over and
there are things in reality imposed on
me which stop me from doing something
there is somebody out there who has
three times as many kids as you and they
still do it what is it that they've got
if you walk down the natural logic of
that statement who do you blame then
does that mean that you blame your child
for all the things that you don't have
in life tough weight to put on a kid I
would hope that they don't see that
comment because then they'd be like wait
mom dad you didn't live out your dreams
because I exist tough